hi in this video i will talk about
tone like receptors
so this video is actually a introduction
to tone like receptors
so these dole-like receptors are
actually pathogen recognition receptor
so they detect pathogen-associated
molecular patterns or pamps
a pump could be a portion of the
bacterial flagella or a portion of the
bacterial membrane the lipoproteins or
even the bacterial genome or the viral
genome
so now
we would take a look at a current
scenario and we would try to compare it
with the immune system
let's say there is a invasion by a
terrorist
and
the terrorist caused a plunder in a
local region
and now our patrolling police officer
would go to that
region maybe our petroleum police
officer don't know its terrorist
but it can understand
the terrorist
by seeing that
it has
empty
magazine empty bullet shells there so
these are some trails by which he could
uh recognize that there may be a
invasion by some bad goons or terrorists
so he would then in there ask for backup
so now think of
these bacteria or viruses that invades
our body as this kind of terrorist
so they contain special kind of trails
associated with them like
the
bullet shells or magazines
so
for a bacteria this kind of trills are
like a portion of its flagella or a
portion of its cell membrane or
lipoproteins or even their genetic
material so these are called
pams
pathogen associated molecular pattern so
just i'm pointing to a particular
portion of a flagella which could be a
pamp so
like our
patrolling police officer
macrophage can also detect these
pathogen-associated trails or
pathogen-associated patterns so
macrophage
does this kind of function
by their special kind of receptor which
is present on the surface of the
macrophage which are known as
toll-like receptor
so now let's take a look
at the realistic situation
our body is invaded by some pathogen and
this pathogen entered our body because
the pathogen was associated with a
rusting nail and the nail is invaded in
our body and now
the macrophage and the dendritic cell
which are in the dermis region but then
in there
of try to find the pathogen and remember
these dendritic cell or macrophages they
are like the patrolling police officer
so they would
try to look for some trails and would
try to identify the pathogen and how
dangerous the pathogen could be
and
uh so dendritic cell and macrophages
both have some receptors pathogen
recognition receptor which are called
the tlrs the tone like receptors
once the dendritic cell
identifies these
pathogen associated molecular patterns
now it would go to
the lymph node and it would go to the
limb vessel and by the lymph vessel it
could travel towards the lymph node and
inside the lymph node we have our
t cells and the b cells
those are the part of our
adaptive immune system so we can think
of it like
the police officer
detects the
trail that there is invasion by a
terrorist
now the police officer would primarily
need backup and would try to fight the
terrorist but maybe
these police officer is not very
efficient in killing killing this
particular terrorist so he need a
superior uh
advantage and superior help so he would
go to a army camp
and he would inform that there is a
terrorist invasion and
they need help
so similarly dendritic cell are like
this patrolling police officer they
would
go towards the army camp which is
actually the lymph node because there
resides the t cells and the b cells and
the dendritic cell would actually
activate that means tell the t cells or
b cells about the pathogen invasion and
now t cell and b cell would try
to reach the spot of invasion and would
try to fight the pathogen
now let's take a look uh details about
the
toll-like receptors
let's zoom into the surface of the
dendritic cell so once we zoom into the
surface of the dendritic cell
we can see there are a lot of pathogen
recognition receptor which are kind of
like uh the question marks
and why they are represented like in uh
in a question mark fashion because
their uh crystallographic structure is
quite similar to our question mark so
they are represented like this
so here is a basic structure
structural feature of these tlr it has a
transmembrane domain as
as the name suggests the transmembrane
domain embeds inside the membrane so
these transmembrane domain mainly
contain helix and they containing the
hydrophobic residues and here is a
domain which is
the lrr which contains lr repeat that
means leucine rich repeats and here is
the domain which is tir domain that
means stole interleukin domain and it
has homology with interleukin 1 receptor
that is why it is known as toll
interleukin homology domain
and if you want to know more about the
structural details of tir domain please
click on the link on the screen i have a
separate video on that now we would try
to look uh at the
several types of these pathogen
recognition receptor
so uh it would tell the dendritic cell
that what type of pathogen actually
invaded our body
so
we have our
first tlr2 and tlr1 so tlr2 and tlr1 can
heterodimerize they actually recognize
the parasites and the gram positive
bacteria and then tlr4 and tlr4 are very
important kind of
tlrs told like receptors because they
are present in cell surface and as well
as they are present in the endosomal
membrane so they are present in both
outside and inside so they can mainly
detect gram uh positive bacteria
and
also tlr2 and 6 heterodimerize they
forms
a heterodimer and they can recognize
fungal pattern and they can recognize
gram positive bacteria also now
here comes the flagella and the flagella
is detected by the tlr5 and tlr5 and
tlr5 homodymerize
now comes the endosomal tlr which are
present in the end zone and in the
endosome we have
tlr4 tlr3 tlr7 and tlr8 and 9. so tlr3
and tlr7
detects
double-stranded rna
and
double-stranded a single-stranded rna
viral rna and
the the tlr8 detects viral ssrna and the
bacterial viral bacterial or viral dna
the cpg islands are actually detected by
the tlr9
and that concludes the video on uh tool
like receptor and next we would be
talking about the tlr signaling means
uh how
the tlr recognize the pathogen and what
the
dendritic cell
performs after recognizing the pathogen
what is the action of the dendritic cell
and
so it was all about
tone like receptors so if you like my
video give it a good thumbs up and don't
forget to subscribe and please leave
your comments below thank you